the only solution for the men seems to
be to sleep around women pick
non-monogamy in their 20s when they have
the most leverage I don't think you have
to sleep with somebody too know if
somebody is a Whitey material stay in
them
yeah took because if I have a family I
made a I make a vow I make a vow a
couple months ago I've made a list of
the things that us as women should stop
doing
now this is not to say that I am perfect
and have never said anything on this
list
however
I just felt like this was a very very
good list
um so this is the things that men uh
look for basically or don't want it's
like want don't want kind of a
combination no taught tattoos your
hobbies cannot be going to the bar every
weekend and going out all the time
looking like a no heavy makeup eyelash
extensions no super heavy eyeliner no
shopping addiction no piercing except
ears be ready be able to get ready in 30
minutes or less no super long
fingernails do not be an idiot do not be
a beautiful Majestic creature a girl she
has to have a fitness routine good with
kid knows how to cook coachable
teachable feminine do not be a feminist
men want women that work hard but not
too hard and at the right things they do
not want a girl that wants a career more
than a family this is my favorite one
the words we're gonna stop saying
partner horoscope signs looking for a
connection energy trauma toxic
masculinity my truth healing my
narcissistic ex-boyfriend my abusive
ex-boyfriend grape accusations don't
judge yeah but manifesting equals I want
to do no work and still get the outcome
I want as a woman we know you're a woman
I did too much and I let him walk all
over me equals I like cheaters and toxic
men and I will choose them and be toxic
as well and not admit my part that I had
any part to play except quote unquote
giving too much generational trauma I
make the same mistakes that my parents
make and I'm too dumb to learn from
their mistakes and instead I will make
the same mistakes but blame it on them
I'm in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative part that myself or any
women play in relationships he needs to
make six figures equals I have no
emphasis assist on character I don't
need a man but I want to win my ring
costs this much Financial abuse I became
feminine I need a man to maintain you we
need to Vibe I feel like I'm a
traditional when I am single Manish I
will be submissive for the right man who
hurt you internalized misogyny I'm
leveling up altogether I need a man to
be on my level I'm a boss babe I'm a bad
these men are broke and dusties I
am the table I am a 10. he needs to add
to what I have going on in my life not
all women equals that is a problem with
women but I won't admit it's a problem
um
I need someone to match my energy I
still don't really know what that means
um I am his peace a broken men uh men
are F boys my body my choice he hit me
harder than I hit him body positivity uh
manifest I am not fat I am plus size or
thick small D energy my ex was a
narcissist I am a queen who hurt you no
respect for my own mother yeah I mean
how is that those are all the words that
you can't say yeah what can we say then
I have a list don't worry I'm I'm so
here to help
all right and this is collaborative so
if you guys have anything you want to
add to it you know feel free phrases to
add I trust you I support you whatever
you say honey thank you I have your back
I'm making this for dinner tonight I
believe or I think what can I do for you
how can I help I'm proud of you I
believe in you I couldn't do this
without you I need you I love you I miss
you I care about you I want you I admire
you
gosh I always forget this one's on I'm
not reading that uh you inspired me I
don't do that
I hate reading this one um get in the
bedroom and drop your pants before you
go to work uh you inspire me huh
uh thank you for working so hard um babe
I know you didn't meet it I'll let it go
it's not a big deal I love that I love
that
you know we can add more a few things
you want to add to it's really
collaborative I've worked with a lot of
people on this okay cool I think the
whatever you say huh you want a head
massage that's the only thing that
depends on the context exactly
it can be a little bit like oh you know
like oh I have to do it again I just you
know you you it depends on the content
where the good women are gone
if you're with the white woman that you
that won't happen if you're with the
white Roman if you're with the right man
that won't happen
it depends on the context she's right it
does but it doesn't I can't I have to be
honest I think women that say this
because I hear this a lot it typically
means I am disagreeable and I don't want
to listen come on okay typically and the
or the men I pick aren't worthy or like
something like I like bombs basically is
the other one like it's like well some
some women pick men who are I think for
their character to mask I don't want to
say that because then you're going to be
like feminism no like two you know like
she she's not feminine enough the man is
really masculine she's in her feminine
most of the time but sometimes she's
like see I see the language in her
feminine yeah I knew you're gonna pick
that up I just think it's like nonsense
like it's just it's like these women
that go on Instagram and they'll say oh
I'm a feminate I don't know if it's you
I hope that's not what you do but but
like it's like I'm now a femininity
coach and there's some genuine ones I'm
not going to say there's not there are
genuine ones that do this too masculine
feminine energy
the ones that I see that are full of
because Men actually look to solve
problems so if you look at like men's
Improvement it's very practical so it's
very much like go to the gym screw a
bunch of girls so you know how to or do
you know I can't even there's a x corn
star that's been on my show he is very
practical you know tips not my thing
right but like and or they'll do
um like go to the gym more money women
it's very like broad like like soft life
I'm gonna sit at home
um and it's never like concrete steps
I've only had one like femininity coach
give me like real concrete steps that
isn't just like journaling or actually I
have something to say about a feminine
feminine feminine coaches
um they operate from
again energy but like what is to be
feminine they tell you be creative like
focus on things that make you tap into
the womb like that traditional woman
that's what they are all about like try
to for I've I've been in touch with some
of them they tell you like listen to
music dance or create something uh with
uh like a painting or something uh
tangible with like artistic yeah um and
to me this sounds like nothing useful to
a guy
go listen to some music
like I'm just I just said yeah there's
only been one femininity coach that like
actually talked about real stuff and she
helped me write most of these like words
to add in the short term it might seem
that it's not helping but imagine on the
long term rather than a woman being in
her as I say masculine energy which is
like shouting and confronting she learns
to be submissive but like step by step
first of all by tapping into these
skills then to be comfortable just doing
uh even something such as cooking they
tell you cooking makes you tap into your
feminine energy more and more so maybe
by building those little habits uh I
think cooking yeah guys I don't think
cooking is bad but
I just
you can't convince me you know why why
we need these now we I agree with you I
agree that it shouldn't matter but we
need this now because a lot of women and
men as well forgot that Natural State
you know what's your natural state as a
woman I don't know because I get really
confused because I hear these like women
talk about soft life right but like our
great grandmothers really didn't have a
soft life they were milky like at least
in the U.S they're milking cows like
have you seen Amish people that's where
they used to live like they do not have
a soft life and soft life to me is
living off a man that's what I see as a
soft lie maybe yeah when you ask where
all the women good women went I mean to
me they went to confusion and
Independence and this confusion is a
diffused awareness because the Primal
nature right A man is hunting he's
directive in his focus and a woman is
diffused because she only has a certain
amount of daylight hours to get as many
berries as she can and she's very
skilled at it she can do it way quicker
than a man apparently and as part of our
survival mechanism and so it is kind of
obtuse and Broad when we think about how
we go back into our feminine nature so
we're not you know in this CEO role of
our families of our
relationships of our businesses and then
we got to come home and then deal with
the reality of like you know being a
partner which is a totally different
energy it's not you're not directive
yeah you've got to get the meal on the
table and my grandmother my mother they
worked really hard as Homemakers it was
like taboo for them to work yeah but my
generation and our generation now it's
very it's a lot of confusion and we're
still the growing into that you know how
do we balance that just Beyonce's fool
I'm being serious she made a true Single
Ladies all of these things with a ring
on her finger
I think we're very capable you know what
I'm saying there's a lot of confusion
from the night to be honest you'll say
all right from the 90s 2000s whatever
there's been there's been a lot of
Independence Independence do your thing
blah blah blah blah blah cool you can do
your Independence but if you don't need
a man
someone said modern day Gathering has
turned into shopping
but why do you think women are having
burnout endocrine disruption cancer
depression I mean there's all these
issues with women's health because
they're trying to be um
like a hormone doctor about this he said
like high strike women and men don't
handle stress the same and it really
messes up our hormones being like high
stress positions and you know what the
mother said if you stay in your feminine
energy and you come home and you look
after your partner your man is going to
want to look after and do everything in
his power to make sure you're good yeah
that's as simple as I can explain it
like as long as you stay in your family
and you look after that man he's gonna
do everything for you regardless
naturally but earlier with what I was
saying if you're not showing certain
things to him he's going to see that all
right cool she's not really mankind I'll
sit back I'm there but I'll sit back a
little bit but if he sees you're making
effort like like even cooking cooking if
you want when I get through to a man's
heart is through his belly 100 as simple
as that did you get what I'm saying yeah
and I also I fell into the boss babe
culture for a long time when I was obese
and I and then I started losing weight
but I was still in the boss baby culture
I was like oh I don't need a man like
I'm fine and it was when I had the daddy
issues when I was I didn't have a good
relationship with my father and it
wasn't until I hit my relationship with
my father that I was like oh okay I
actually you know it's really important
that I I don't have to work like a man I
was so stressed I was so anxious all the
time and then I just let it go it's like
I don't need to do that my future
husband will provide for me my future
husband will do these and I'll fall into
my feminine roles I will cook I will
clean I will take care of the kids I'll
take care of the house like that and
I'll go I'll Garden what did you do did
you quit your job no I just okay I was
just curious well I guess I did a couple
of miracle I just I flipped two houses
last year and I was like I don't want to
do this anymore so I just decided to
stop doing it that's cool it was a
miracle though really yeah because no
because I was the boss right I had to be
ever the provider I had to be everything
and you didn't have that example and I
think that's another part of where all
the good women of God inside of this
Independence inside of this confusion
it's fatherless families and like Pearl
was saying earlier if you don't have the
example how are you supposed to know and
you haven't had the example Penelope so
it's a miracle purely purely yeah no it
is and it was it was like growing up
with you as my mom like you played both
roles the dad and the mom and so that
was very interesting because I grew up
thinking oh I I don't need men like men
are terrible and I even thought my
father was terrible because now he's
like my best friend but I think where
the good women are going is they think
that it's a bad thing to be feminine I
think that that the mindset of women
today feel like
um and now if you're feminine and
traditional online people are like
you're you know you're not a feminist
you hate women you are terrible you are
a disgraceful Society you should go die
and it's like wait wait what like women
are the most beautiful things on the
planet they create human
create human being so why are women
putting
women want women to fail
we're not supposed to be competing with
our moms generation because the thing is
like if you have a 45 year old and you
have like a 25 year old girl it's like
you a lot of times the guys you might
want are the same age because women like
45 tend to want guys like it's like five
to seven years younger where women
um 25 want guys five to seven years
older this crossover and I think bitter
older women that don't want you to win
will tell you the wrong information
that's true and and it's because like if
they're if they're being a hoe right
like what's the worst feeling when you
take a test and you fail what's the
worst feeling when everyone else
succeeded yeah right but if you turn
around and they say I failed too it's
like you feel a little bit better so
it's like these women want other people
to be miserable in their negative
decisions
of people because of it because of
succeeding in in my relationship and
having a healthy relationship with my
father people dislike me because of that
and it's like why do you hate me for
having a healthy relationship with my
family am I am I so would you would you
say and especially they don't want you
to win
know that you've been divorced miserable
sad fat on your phone on Tick Tock dying
so would you say yeah that this is like
technically just a woman's problem then
because it's women that it's not
technically men that put down women you
know it's women that put down women the
woman trying to be men hurt are hurting
the the feminine not not the feminine
the beta men right that that's hurting
beta man that's why we have betamen it's
because of the masculine well I think it
becomes a problem because you have 80 of
women screw in 20 of men so then women
don't respect the average guy I did a
show the other day and like most women
said they wouldn't date a bus driver
they're above a bus for our average
checks and it's why you have average
chicks saying they're at the level of a
celebrity no offense but like it's like
you have average chicks thinking they're
they're so great when it's like
literally you are average you're average
looking even average mindset most people
are average and men will accept this but
women won't it's like an insult for us
to be normal so then you you won't see
normal women dating normal men but do
you feel like that that is because
social media has a lot to play for it
they feel like there's a lot more I
think it's social I think it's social
media and dating apps they feel like
they want more accessibility to hire
people I mean they do like because the
issue nowadays because this is what made
me think about this I'm like how would
you find a good woman and I was thinking
about this and I made a chart and I had
like the body count of a woman on one
hand and I had the looks of a woman on a
one hand and so I was like a woman
that's eight to ten with a high or a low
body count good luck keeping her do you
know what the list is gonna be for a
girl that that's like that hot with like
like the competition is crazy crazy and
so it's like you could be dating a woman
and if there's High competition for her
Drake could slide in your girl's DM 100
or maybe it's not Drake it's the town
whoever right and then I was thinking
about it and I was like unless a guy
sleeps with a lot of women how is he
going to know the difference between a
woman that's been out with everybody and
a girl that does it has it they never
did they can't no they can't know unless
they've been with a lot of girls and I'm
like it's kind of unfortunate because
it's like the only solution for the men
seems to be to sleep around which I
don't think is you know great for
society but it's like it's women's fault
because we're the ones doing the
sleeping do you think that men should
have more than one woman
um I I think that it's silly to date
certain men and expect monogamy so I
think it's silly to date say Jason
Derulo Chris Brown These are extreme
examples but there's certain men that
it's very silly to expect it because
he's never been monogamous and they
never will be I think monogamy in
general is better for a society I forget
to sit the higher I'm even talking on
average men normal men on a day today
because obviously you've said earlier on
that there's more women under Earth than
men yeah so on average how we are
naturally
do you think that the average man should
have one woman
um I think that it's better for society
if monogamy is better because you get
like a growing
um having a lot of sex sexless men like
usually causes Society to collapse
um so I think monogamy is better by and
large but I think that a certain
percentage of men are always going to be
non-monogamous
um and that's kind of the way it's been
the last like two million years because
85 it's like the last
I don't want to say the how long it's
been like this because I don't remember
off the top of my head but I know like
historically they always it seems like
all of society has been non-monogamous
because 17 men reproduce for every uh
one 17 women reproduced for every one
man like 8 000 years ago and on top of
that there's like two women have always
reproduced for every one man but it's
actually um or 40 of men have never
reproduced forty percent of men I'm
sorry I'm butchering this but but the 85
of um like 85 percent of society has
generally been a monogamous were the top
15 percent of men have just been like
slaying is it yeah well well okay you do
a lot of stats here yeah I know a lot of
average men out here that's probably not
on these stats doing the same thing and
and when I say a lot I'm talking if
you're just talking average men in
London obviously London I don't know
about America average and what in
sleeping with a lot of women no like
average looks average money would you
average looks average average job I'm
I'm I can even give you examples of a
few average men that are big in weight
and just got normal jobs that aren't
dealing with a lot of women across the
board
um well there's a couple things so I
mean typically again like there's been
studies on dating apps and in in person
where women find 80 of men is ugly not
okay not average they think ugly he is
unattractive ugly would you say the top
percentage of men are on these dating
apps
um yeah maybe yeah I don't know I don't
I don't believe so um
I think that I think that if you look at
the numbers social media is the number
one my peop way people are meeting 100
so social media and dating apps and like
when you look at so then the question is
if that's where people are meeting what
do the numbers look like in the dating
apps well women only swipe right five
percent of the time so that means on the
number one way people are meeting we're
sharing men 100 because there's always
going to be free men because we're the
hunters so we wait 100 wait say say that
again it's always going to be men
because we're the hunters we're always
going we're going to be the higher
anyway do you know what I'm saying yeah
but when you're saying that average men
that get women they probably get women
over the age of 30. because women tend
to go for looks and so in their 20s I
fully agree with yeah you know I agree
with that because I feel like we're
single mothers you're 100 between 20 and
30 women are very selective in what they
do and then when they get to the end you
started reading enough a lot of stats
about pregnancy their reaction yeah when
they start realizing that then they go
for the average they feel like they can
come back to that agreement or even go
back to man that they was that was
trying to get them when they were 18 19
and feel like they can go back to them
but obviously with men it's a bit
different because men yeah at 30 we
start peaking we get correct yeah so we
start it's changed there's a change you
get what I'm saying yeah yeah and so
that's why I say women pick non-monogamy
in their 20s when they have the most
leverage yeah and they pick the 20 of
men that in their 30s they we tend to
pick
um like the rest basically and so the
issue is like when when women cheat who
do they typically cheat with you guys
know anyone
and X's correct 100 correct so the issue
that a lot of these guys are getting
into and this is why guys don't like
typically like a lot of guys will say I
don't date women over 30 and it's not a
looks thing it's that if she's 30 like
how many relationships has she had is
one of those guys better than me and
does she want to be with him and the
odds are he probably is because in her
20s she had more lovers in her 30s so
what are the odds in her 30s she can get
a better rather than in her 20s likely
right and he was probably top 20 percent
alone slightly when they have that
relationship from 20 to 30 there's
there's always that one guy that can
always come back in the background
I've spoken to women that have had like
I don't know six year situation chips on
and off we're between every relationship
and that's like how they keep their like
body count low or whatever it's like a
say so they'll like go back to the lat
and it kind of so it kind of makes sense
in your body count like 100 but you
don't have to do that you can just use
the toys
you know everyone gotta come off yeah
but they are usually usually the guys
are the ones that are on standby they're
waiting and you know why men will always
be honest and I know what they want I'm
not saying that I'm fooled but and you
know why it works we're always there you
know why it works for women and men will
always be there because men don't talk
to me but I'm not gonna go to to Ted and
like yo Ted I'm dealing with power you
know boom boom boom whereas and women
always want to go to women about stuff
yeah so yeah you look in terms of you
can always have your exes there because
my man will just wait in the in the
background the Shadows
when you're done when
now she won't be the main one she want
to go to the the main woman and tell her
yo we've been together
I'm gonna read this was a I think this
is like a 50 I don't know the conversion
but Pearl listen all these discussions
are pointless walk outside and you will
see the majority of men don't leave
their homes this phenomenon first
started in Japan we are just a few years
behind I went to Japan and all I see is
women outside my main point is you
cannot bring back most men outside of
their rooms if you have to waste time
arguing debating with modern women
Society will collapse just like Japan
women will say it's expensive to have
kids T he he children
um but men are indoors with corn or what
is what is it what is he implying
um
I don't know to be honest I just read it
um I mean I think in general people
aren't leaving and especially like now
they're gonna have ai and like I think
there's just more people aren't going
outside it's his main point
um but I was I was thinking about this
the other day because I was like if I
was a guy how would you pick a good
because I've been interviewing men for
this divorce documentary I'm doing so I
interview the men that have been like
stupid wrecked by divorced okay so
they're um
and typically this happens like it's
this is kind of the story that I've
heard like from guys typically he meets
her and there's like an unplanned
pregnancy
and typically like they get married
pretty quick and then
um she'll go to a women's shelter like
accuse him of abuse on some level when
some like they'll even prove that she
was lying because you get a free lawyer
here if you accuse a guy of abuse
and basically they have their whole
lives ruined they're on these really big
child support payments like one guy lost
his job like it's really really sad like
I listen like there and you can just
tell they're like a shell of a dude who
they used to be right and I'll speak to
these men and I'm like okay so she in
some the girls had red flags but some
it's like she was from a two-parent home
um she there's there's one that's in the
news right now where they're both
virgins on their wedding night I'll see
another that's like she um
she came from a Christian family she was
from Eastern Europe and like all the
like on paper and I'm like I don't know
as a guy how you avoid that
and so that's that's why I did this show
is I was genuinely asking how do you
like what what where are the good women
and how do men pick them
and right now I'll tell you what we've
got
um hold on I have the list
um go on a coffee date before or after
easily
sleep with her as soon as possible
um one month to a year ask her to make
coffee ask to cook on the spot take her
on a coffee date date as many women as
possible to tell the difference make
sure you're not on birth control what
does her relationship look like with her
dad
um and I don't even say this to like
harp on women right because like men
have issues women of issues but I just
think like with how much guys I have to
lose I'm like how I can't even think of
how you avoid it well I would say like
just don't don't sign a contract when
you get married just get married and
don't sign the contract I fought this
too I thought exactly like you but no it
doesn't matter because when you have a
kid that's true but I think if there was
more Purity in the world I think if if
men and women were both seeking more
Purity from each other like how how
honest are you being right now you know
how how gentle are you as a pure person
do you want to harm people do you wanna
do you go out of your way to lie let's
okay let's follow this let's say the guy
says I'm going to be as pure as possible
I'm gonna have as little experience with
women as possible how does he tell the
difference between a woman with a high
body count and a low body count if he
has no experience with women there's no
way not now there's no there really is
no way right so if he has if he has no
Spirits no factual ways I know what I'm
saying okay I would think you'd have to
like kind of be with a lot of women to
figure that out but if he doesn't want
to if he follows the Purity route
men still have to date women I think men
and women should should date men a few
men and women at least to see like see
what see what people are out there to
know the difference between different
people and also yeah observing other
people's relationships is important but
I don't think you have to sleep with
somebody too know if somebody is a is
wifey material you know I don't think
you have to sleep with someone yeah I
don't think you have to say being like
intimate having intimate conversations
having a relationship you know having
your Traditional Values play out in life
roles you know cooking and cleaning and
taking care of the house whatever I
think those are things those are
important things to do and that's how
you'll know if that's a woman you
actually want to marry one day but
that's very pure right there is no like
you know having the Intercourse and
making out right but I guess my question
is like the average woman and like we
could talk about like what we should do
and this is where like it's hard because
I used to think like this I used to
think like you but it's like I think
we're like red pill and like Trad cons
tend to like talk past each other where
it's like the average woman to slept
with five to eight people
like why would he wait for a woman
that's no like so defensive right I
agree with this and like they should not
a man should not wait for someone who
slept this five nine woman right and so
how would he tell the difference between
a virgin who's lying and a girl who's at
like actually a virgin unless he's carry
themselves I mean like you might you
won't know you will you will never know
right I I agree with you you'll never
know for sure but the but the way a
woman carries herself really shows a lot
about who she is and if she's gonna lie
about something or not yeah and what
yeah
that's a practical solution I like that
and how she responds to difficult
situations that's a good one yeah that's
a really good one because that that'll
be the test every time yeah go on a
camping trip or travel with them or do
something that's you know challenging or
out of their country and this is the
hard thing I keep thinking to these men
I was in the document like I did the
documentary with and a lot of them did
this stuff and that's why I'm genuinely
like I think there's like there's no way
you could know like genuinely you could
never you could never know
sure yeah well you can you can get you
can engage because through conversation
me news having a conversation and I find
out okay how much relationships you if
you've been in a relationship 10 years
one person yet you could have done what
you're doing yeah but then I can gauge
between this age and this okay you've
had one person right that maybe you've
been outside for the last two years did
you get what I'm saying I think you can
gauge it and you'll never know exact
number because she could be doing other
things and we're religion and
spiritually definitely pays a part in
who you choose and how you act right
because if you both have a similar
religion or sexuality okay okay so so
then why are the reputation of church
women so bad
church and they do Terrible Things yes
right right but I'm saying like the
reputation of church women is best worse
than the normal population yes and so
it's like just church right no but but
it's like it's it's just crazy because
it's like everything we tell them to
look for it's like
yeah because they go and commit sins
they can wash them away on the Sunday
and I think men and women both do that
you know they both do that
sounds like for women it's it's also
pretty destructive because their chances
of getting another guy is pretty low it
sounds like well it's decimating it
totally destroys both of their lives it
sounds like when it doesn't work out not
only the man's life but also the woman's
life because she doesn't have that many
chances afterwards according to the
statistics you've been sharing but you
know I don't think this is a man issue
though I feel like it's women that need
to understand men more and understand
what men want if they understand what
men want they won't have the issue of
finding another it's actually quite
simple isn't it I just I don't think
women would leave if they didn't think
they could do better yeah like nobody
nobody leaves to like be alone I'm not
saying they can't like we're delusional
you know but what's better because they
might think that guy's but but well I
mean a lot of times it's like the we
have imaginations for example a man
could do way more for you but it's about
what you accepted he couldn't give you
everything you want to make sure you're
the number one woman but if he goes out
and he's got a couple getting cheating
or whatever are you gonna accept that
for being a happy wife of course not
well no one would no a lot of people do
exactly a lot of people
if he looks
make sure you're good everything at home
is patterned you're the number one woman
but yes he goes out sometimes and he's
he goes on weekenders away let's say and
he sleeps with women but when he comes
back
the house is patterned everything's
looked after there's just something
wrong with his values there's something
wrong with his connection to God or
religion or something there's something
wrong with his values but what about
that what about maybe she did something
to make him cheat if you don't know no
not you I always feel like there's a
reason people cheat always like men
don't cheat for no reason and women
don't cheat but like I just think we
kind of get it I think we get in this
like like if a guy cheats he's like the
worst like people always misconstrue my
thought I don't think cheating is good
but like it's like we'll demonize the
men for cheating right but when women go
into relationships with open social
media accounts and we don't demonize
them where they can still get attention
from high value men exactly 100 and it's
like we don't it's the same thing but
yet like if a guy cheats it's the worst
thing ever no I think it's both equally
I feel like if a female cheese their
demon is the worst thing ever and that
man will never take her back so I think
it's the opposite I think that's what's
taken back that's not true when you
think about it like men marry single
mothers all the time mentee and in a way
that's like I mean you're coming in with
another man's kid I hate what you're
saying to a certain degree man yeah
because obviously if you're letting
someone inside your body that man is
going to look at it differently yeah no
no forget the man looking at you he's
going to look at you differently I'm
saying if you're opening your dead
I don't think you're just going to open
your legs to a man just just off the rip
at night I do think I do think people
should try to work out cheating though
like I like I I think like it's about
the kids it's not about you you should
try to work it out yeah oh yeah you
should work at 100 people like I'm no
offense to people watching this but like
they my mom and dad got divorced when I
was four and it was because my dad
cheated on her and I don't think anyone
should you know I think cheating I don't
inherently think cheating is a good
thing but I think I sometimes wonder
what would my life have looked like had
they been together I wonder that
everything how would I have been you
know I'm I'm grateful that I know I am
the way I am now but I'm just saying
like I know there's a lot of girls out
there who have dysfunctional families
and don't have a father and mother that
are together and I've seen people with
who have their mother and father
together and they're very different
people the way they approach themselves
the way they talk to people the way they
react to situations they're just
different people and I think that's
beautiful and so like that's even like a
reason like I want I wish more people
more women and men would see oh I want
to have a healthy family I want to break
the generational trauma the generational
this disrupt you know the generational
problems do you ever wish you stayed
absolutely really yeah well I wish we
could have worked it out absolutely so
what made you guys get divorced if you
don't mind me asking well I I came to
him and I I gave him the very clear
parameters I was like listen I figured
this is happening it's undeniable we
can't deny this is happening so let's
just save our marriage and save our life
we have a great life and so I said you
know I need these three things to happen
and not only did they not happen but it
got much much worse and then it got
dangerous then it got violent and then
it got scary and then I you know then I
just felt like I didn't have a choice
because things got so violent dangerous
and scary so it went directly because of
cheating
well no initially I I it started off
that way because there's just so much
lies and deceiving can I trust this
person and then but I really really
wanted to to make it work I was like why
don't we we'll just have an open
marriage which I knew would probably
kill me inside but I was like yeah I
even offered it you know I was like
that's really really wanted it I didn't
give him a contract for a second child I
said you have to pay for the chat like I
just I really wanted the marriage to
stay together but I just got scared so
if it was just strictly cheating do you
think it would have worked out then it
would have been all right no well I
needed certain things to change I needed
some Securities that weren't that
weren't that weren't there because I
think what are you insecurities do you
mind saying or no well when I found out
that he was cheating I also looked into
like our life a little bit more deeply
and I realized that absolutely nothing
was in my name okay I had nothing and I
was like oh my gosh I'm in a really
vulnerable position here because I never
even thought about it and so then I was
like listen I need to have some stake in
our lives things
and it was a protect protective
mechanism clearly
um and he was like no
no way can I ask a question so did you
did you put yourself in that situation
where you wanted to make it work because
for Penelope for sure only all because
you loved him so did also I still love
him today and he's watching right now I
mean I was hoping he would come to
London yesterday and have lunch with us
is he still single yeah
would you ever get back with him
if I mean I would consider Penelope
thinks I'm crazy
my dad would never get back with her so
it's like I don't I I don't know
right now on camera no no don't do that
but can I ask a question but why
wouldn't you I know you said you would
you would you're doing it for Penelope
and I understand that absolutely you can
do anything to keep
um I think people would do anything
um for their children but
don't you think that you should love
yourself more instead of after what he's
done and I feel like you can do you
deserve better and you don't deserve to
be treated like glorified what being a
single parent was going to look like and
it was crazy because I had a single mom
so I should have known better but
honestly I think it's modern day child
abuse it is and I watched her and I
watched her in my I watched her growing
up struggle so much as one person to do
all the work at home like just one
person no support I mean it was so hard
for you like you were I remember the
nights you were like crying and it also
struck a a strong heart in my and for me
that was like I never want to have that
and I will do any anything and
everything my power to never create that
for my future family because that is so
it was so painful I don't wish that pain
on anything yeah
staying then
yeah because if I have a family I made a
I make a vow I make a vow I make a vow
to to God to higher power that I will
stick with this person for the rest of
my life of course I thought that I did
that with your father too but you know
it happened but I can never make up for
that for you not having a dad and there
was a spiritual disc like there was a
spiritual disconnection there
well our values were different I thought
we were an monogamous relationship but I
you know found out otherwise and uh
maybe it was a phase I don't know maybe
you can't change people I don't know but
you know it's sad I mean guys he still
admits to this day he regrets what he
did he wished he didn't do what he did
and he and he and he wishes he could
have changed certain things so he's not
like doesn't have anymore because I just
feel like
majority majority of men do at some
point in their life will cheat
in a relationship they will and if every
woman leaves a man for cheating then all
these you know motherless and fatherless
family but I think I think that's the
thing we're never like we're never as
women we're never told like how men are
naturally and like men just want to
screw everything so it's like we've kind
of been told that if we get cheated on
it's the worst thing ever and it can't
be worked and the man isn't in the house
there's a lot of fatherlessness I think
that most of I think that most of
society's problem really like come back
to single mother homes to be honest like
if you look at the prison population
it's like 80 single mother homes if you
look at
um youth suicides we are way more likely
to be abused as a child um you're way
more like every Big um I I spoke to a
homeless
um shelter director down the street and
I said why why like are these people
homeless like because he has like the
worst type of homeless which is like the
street sleepers because there's
different like levels of people living
in cars there's whatever and he told me
that um he that most of these people
came from single mother homes especially
with like multiple baby daddies or like
whatever and they the kids I got ended
up getting taken and like put in the
system and they've never they don't know
any sense of stability or function
um and so if you look at all the like
major issues in society a lot are linked
to single mother homes and single father
homes don't have the same outcomes it's
not as bad but if you're seeing a lot of
if you grow up in a single household and
you see a breakup then in your head it
might seem like like you were saying
with your you can you can do this
because your mom will grow up in a
single homeowner so you might see it as
I this is something it's not easy but
it's something I can do and then when
only when you go through it you realize
that right this is mad but if we have a
lot more family units in the house and
working at things then the children get
to see like okay my mom and dad went
through this but they managed to go
through this route to to help and
because I've been through my in a
relationship where I've gone therapy and
I've gone places to to fix things you
get on Zan and even when you talk about
therapy earlier I don't think therapy is
there to fix things it's just there to
for you to it is I hope not not I don't
think therapy is there to fix I think
it's there to help you understand
triggers and understand certain things
for you to maneuver it can never therapy
can never fix nothing
honestly to be very honest with you
after going to therapy for eight years
maybe 12 yeah I don't believe in therapy
there are other ways to fix your
problems and you can also just really
get over yourself honestly I just
decided to get over myself and that's
basically how I feel well I think I
think that therapy like it's Outsourcing
families because like usually you would
go to your siblings or you go to because
your your mother is going to have a
completely different take like if you're
let's say if you're in an argument with
your boyfriend she's gonna have a
completely different take on the
situation because she knows you and she
knows you're positive and you're
negative traits so it's like if I tell
my mom like oh this person reacted to me
this way my mom's gonna be like well
people are scared of that real truth no
I just think that the therapist doesn't
have that information they didn't grow
up with you but like you who knows your
daughter better than you but that's what
I'm saying she might be she might be
scared to go to her mom because she's
gonna get that harsh reality and
sometimes people don't want the harsh
reality you know what I'm saying no I
love it that's she raised me that way
though yeah like the way you're the way
people raise their children dictates
also relationships how people reacting
so she raised me giving me the hard
truth since I was little and I hated it
I mean I would scream at you and cry I I
used to hate her but that's what I'm
saying you hate no one likes it you know
I used to hate her but now I love her
and I give her like all the props to be
honest with me when I didn't want to
hear it yeah she told me I was fat she's
like Penelope you need to get up and go
work out like she reminded me of that
every day that's good that's so funny I
used to get mad at Mama I wasn't I
wasn't that big but I was like that
pretty pretty chunky and my mom would
always be like on me because I was just
this die-hard like tomboy and I just
didn't want to like look not and I still
struggle with it to this David I'm like
oh my God I would be so much worse if my
mom wasn't like on me all the time
because when you're a kid you're just
like Mom like I don't wanna know her and
she's like this she has her master's
nutrition she's trained thousands of
people yeah I'm like I don't want you to
tell me what to eat like I don't want
you to tell me how to live how to work
out but I would sit in my room like
obese fat you know crying I was
depressed in my dark room all day and
she'd be like open the curtains rip the
curtains open be like
better if you're not gonna bed now you
know I'm gonna take your phone away and
I was like it was like really intense
you know those are the kind of parents
that you need but I needed that because
this world is cruel and I've been
through some bad things and and having
that her mentality that she raised me
with being honest and saying penalty you
need to get up nope and I'll be this is
not true you know men there are men and
women like these are important things
she taught me it's kind of funny like
the day you realize your parents were
right about everything like it's like
it's like you just wake up one day and
you're like
it was like around 21 or 22 for me I was
like oh my gosh my mom and dad raised me
so well and they were right about
everything they told me
we never listened through our teenager
Yes except for relationships oh yeah I'm
not listening to them for relationships
compared to those two yeah yeah well do
you like the guy she's dating very much
yeah I mean I think that I think that
mothers like actually we should ask our
parents about those like people we date
yeah and I actually he met my mom and my
dad and I I would I wouldn't have been
with him if they didn't like him yeah
period because that's just how that's
just how it should be I might like that
as well because even the girl that I'm
seeing now her family unit is strong and
I feel like it wouldn't have worked if
if her mama or things didn't like man
did you get what I'm saying totally and
my family is like my most important
thing but my respect that once the
family is important to you totally I'm
close to you not I feel like I feel like
men respect women more when they have
that family Dynamic whoever the even if
the dad's not there if the dad's day
obviously he's going to respect it a lot
more in it because he's gonna come
differently but if if he knows you have
a strong support unit with Mom cousins
aunties whatever yeah he is going to
respect you a lot more than if a girl
doesn't really have the same kind of
support we're asking how you find a good
woman and I also find find it really
challenging to know when you find a good
man I mean I think by now at 47 you know
it's challenging to find a good man I
think I found one whose value is a line
but it's not that easy it's not easy
exactly what do you guys think how do
you know when a guy's a good guy
yo you know what it is with the you know
you can tell when a man is
is in line when he has a good woman
a good woman makes a good man no but
yeah he's good on his own first okay
I asked you guys for her she's a single
woman or sort of she's dating someone
but like for a single woman how do you
know if it's a good man what do you
think do you think it's easy to tell as
a guy who the guy the good guys are no
it's not easy it's not if he's willing
to accept your trauma he's a good guy
hmm that's a good one that's a good one
definitely because that's a good point
yes
that's a good point okay
that's just like why would a guy why
would a good guy want to accept a bunch
of trauma
because if he see something in you he
will yeah you see something if he
supports you through certain things
you're going through and Trauma that
then you know he listens to your
problems not not no just not just
listening forget the listening okay he's
actually there like raw like cool you've
gone let's say all right what kind of
example can I do maybe working or not
trying to work around you in a way
whatever the issue may be or whatever it
is going through yeah like if she needs
time like you're there but you're you're
you're supportive
fundamentally I think that all most guys
a good guy
you know good guys we are good guys yeah
yeah I agree no um but the thing is it's
about have we found the right woman okay
so if we're with the right woman then it
works if we're not that it's normal but
how does she see it though and she's not
going to see it but
um easily because it depends on who she
is I attend this is what I just said to
Pearl it's about but she doesn't
understand do you see me saying it from
a man that like
in order for a man to be a good man you
have to have a good woman because the
woman will put you in line like man on
their own don't put themselves in line
we do reckless things we buy we spend
money recklessly we live recklessly
until you get that good one I was
chatting to the random today in the
what's that group and it's like well you
could even remember what was saying
about a man dressing well you could tell
when a man's dressing a certain way in a
relationship and out of a relationship
you can tell obviously I don't know
Magnum guitar I don't know if women can
tell but really the most like Dependable
like responsible man I know don't really
need a woman to like look after them not
to be honest it's not about need it's
about guidance so like I mean do you get
what I'm saying no because I'm just
thinking about the men like I respect
the most in my life that are really like
doing stuff um like I think of my dad
some of my brothers they don't need a
woman to like guide them or take care of
them they kind of have a path stuff they
want to do they don't really no we're
always going to have a part of it but
women have certain like we're practical
so we're always on your we need to do
this we need to do that when blah blah
where women are more
structured they will put their men are
structured but we will got weasel see
we'll have a vision and we go for that
vision and sometimes we just go
because we can see what we're going for
we know we we got the picture in our
head but a woman a woman can organize
the route a bit better than a man can
organize them I think what you're saying
is more like enhancing your qualities
enhancing your life yeah maybe yeah but
like honestly for me I think that if if
a guy can get up even when he's sad when
he has a bad day maybe if he likes to
work out he'll do a workout go to work
not be emotional all the time you know
these things that if you already do them
without a woman that's good yeah we do
that naturally but go on Pro yeah I know
you he was um
it's just this just sounds to me yeah
like the guys you don't want to date
which is the guys that like need a woman
yeah to like to guide them yeah yeah
like I would think you'd want like a
leader or maybe I'm wrong no no man's a
leader yeah
Disney's organized man
's payments
[Music]
you're kind of switching what you
started saying no but I'm okay it's hard
for me to explain it because it's like
he's mad because obviously man I'm I'm
when I'm saying I'm focused man you can
be focused on something but sometimes
you need somebody there to help you in
line certain things because man we will
just do things like for example are you
shopping for example yeah
see one guy if I'm going shopping you
know I'm going in the size eight Air
Force One boom bam gone I know exactly
what I want I know what I'm going there
for I'm not spending longer a woman will
if they want a dress or something or
they want to choose you try it on it's
got to make sure it looks right blah
blah blah up there oh they will pattern
up things make sure everything's correct
before they leave that do you get what
I'm saying get in your size eight better
your route yeah but I'm just saying they
will look for more okay I'm gonna Read
Super Chat
um okay guys make sure you like the
video did we open the chat do we get 2
000 likes blessing
yeah 1.2 oh 1.2 good job guys uh aw
message deleted I don't know what you
said but someone deleted it um Hiroshima
21st century uh is the biggest L For
Humanity we trusted women to be
accountable like men are but all they
did was Destroy Society roman-powered
women it's gone now is that true did
Rome do that
um Vincent Fraga the traditional
righteous focused um men focused since
youth to be Godly protectors providers
and intelligent for the purpose to build
families at large I'm Hiroshima average
Japanese guys doesn't leave his house
all I saw outside were Chads and
good-looking guys they openly said they
had multiple girlfriends because that's
all they had the rest of the guys aren't
even in the dating pool just rotting at
home
um that was for the Japanese Super Chat
earlier Boy Thanks for the hard work pro
peace Gore I'm just being submissive
mean submit to your men are being or
does it mean submit to your family and
tell tats to stop talking oy haha you're
right Zoro slot only simps want to wait
months if women isn't a virgin it's a
woman's job to retain a man after
hooking up uh
women want quality and men want quantity
we are not the same
um
what do you guys think about the phrase
I'm a woman that makes you wait for sex
isn't worth the wait
foreign
that's only true if you're not if she's
not a real version which I know you
can't really you know just you can't
really tell but that's that's what I
think at least but I think you guys have
to be mindful when it comes to sex it's
not just sex it's a spiritual ex energy
exchange I don't care you guys I have to
say this stuff like like honestly it's
not it's a big thing so do you really
want to just be having sex with anyone
and letting any kind of energy into your
energy like it's not worth it is it I
don't think it's worth it and that's
kind of can I just say that for us it is
always a spiritual exchange for them it
might just be sex and you might be
thinking oh this is a spiritual exchange
but it's not and that's why I probably
could only date spiritual men now now at
this point like I think if you thought
it was a spiritual exchange you would
have waited till you were married
this is what I mean like why like like
men hear the things we say and it
doesn't match up with what we do because
it's like okay you're 32 you've been
dating since you're 18. was every guy
you slept with in the last 12 years a
spiritual but since 28 because I only
started spiritual enough 28 so my
mindset completely okay do you do you
realize there's like a pattern wait wait
wait so there's like a pattern so this
is this is like guys when they've dated
enough women they start to see like
patterns in our behavior and like one
thing that they found was like women
tend to like find God around the age of
28 so they kind of like start to Rebrand
so basically like like basically it's
kind of like a red flag when you say
around 28 I like found God or found the
spiritual journey because it's kind of
like okay I spent the first half of my
20s being a hoe and then now I'm not I'm
not saying a hoe but like okay what is a
hoe statistically more than five
partners
so a lot of times like women sort of try
to Rebrand it just doesn't really seem
like genuine it's not really rebranding
its growth like at the end of the day if
you're going to be the same force your
life it might not be but I'm just
telling you how like men see that's not
the meant for me okay listen listen but
this is this isn't this isn't the men
for me I'm telling you this is how like
men see it where it's like before the
men um I gave this away for free now you
pay a premium price and so what that
says to the men is you're not genuinely
attracted to them because you were
genuinely attracted to the first guy
because you had sex with him right away
but you're not that attracted to the
second because you're making him wait
and pro I would even I would even say
that like you're like again going back
to like your body's a temple it's not
even just like your body's Temple it's
also like what food you eat you know how
you treat your body like are you working
out like are you taking care of yourself
like these things are part of that and I
think if you're doing all of those
things then yeah the that both people
should wait because that means you're
actually you love yourself in an
authentic truthful way and you actually
care about your body and your beliefs so
that that to me that would show that
what would show like eating right eating
right taking care of your body and also
not like having a bunch of tattoos and
not and not sleeping with a bunch of
people oh okay I see I see so being pure
being you know yeah so do you think that
um majority of men think that let's say
for example before you're 28 you've
slept around and then after 28 you found
God reborn again no I think that's
terrible that's just like that's just
like a cover-up who is that though huh
who who like is that I don't think
everyone's like that but not everyone's
at it I'm saying but I mean they say
there's a boon again no not 28 yeah hold
on I'm gonna read this
I mean let's give them credit some of
them could be you can like you can find
God at the end of the day okay okay this
is this is this is from the rational
mail
um I previously described this phase as
parallels
um all right this this time Epiphany
phase this is a precarious time for
women usually between the ages of 28 and
30 where she attempts to reassess the
last decade of her life women's
psychological rationalization engine
begins a furious effort to account for
and explain her reasonings for not
having successfully secured a long-term
monogamous commitment from an alpha a
man a man her attractiveness could
attain for her even women married prior
to this phase will go through some
self-doubt or self-pity dealing with the
on are the hyper hypergamic uncertainty
of her choice is this really the best I
can do it is during this phase that
women will make radical shifts in their
proprietorization of what traits qualify
as attractive in a man an attempt to
turn over a new Leaf by changing up
their behaviors to allow to the with
this new persona they created themselves
for themselves since the physicality
sexual prowess and the alpha dominance
that made her formal arousal it's like
so more looks a formal arousal cues in
men aren't as a forthcoming from men
when she was in her sexual prime she
reprioritizes them with preferences for
more intrinsic male attributes that
stress dependability provisioning
capacity humor intellect and um
esoteric definitions of compatibility
and intimacy for the spiritually
inclined women this may manifest in a
convenient return to the convictions she
disregarded since her adolescence for
others it may be a forced celibacy a
refusal to have sex under the hype
hypergamic why do you use these big
words awesome peas of her party years in
hopes that a well-provisioning male will
appreciate her for her Prudence so
unlike herself and all the other girls
who rejected him the last decade so it's
essentially like a Rebrand yeah exactly
but it said even for married women it
said right no that had been married oh
actually maybe wait let me rewrite
because I I understood it as even
married women go through some sort of
shift
you might be right you might be right
I'm just trying to find it
I understood that too and I think I
experienced that as well I didn't
divorce until I was 34 but I think that
goes back to like emotions how like
women act out of emotions and like I
feel like women need to find better ways
to deal with their emotions they're
usually stuffing them down that's why
there's so much obesity I know or
smearing them out like pushing them out
uh on smearing them other people through
projection it's it's pretty destructive
and the size like oh that's fine and you
can just be born again you can just
truthful and authentic
what who taught us who taught us how to
deal with our emotions or maybe our
parents didn't it's a natural thing no
it's not well I think women naturally
are emotional
no but we
everyone knows you don't have to do it
but you're naturally emotional and it's
like so whether you know how to deal
with it don't always say who taught us
it's almost like a way for women like
for us to like can I've noticed in our
language we like take accountability off
of women where it's like we blame our
choices over who taught us where it's
like if a guy's in jail they don't say
who taught you that they just say he's
you ever notice that for sure no
absolutely like I don't think it's like
intentional I just think I feel like
there's like these little things in
conversation where we like take
accountability off of women and like put
it onto someone else yeah thanks for
shredding light on that it's our
responsibilities